EXTREMELY STRONG HAND A CRUSHING
JEROME CORSI.
JEROME CORSI, AND MR. CORSI,
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR COMING ON.
LAST WE SPOKE MY UNDERSTANDING
WAS FOR OUR PREVIOUS
CONVERSATION, YOU MADE A
MISTAKE.
HE SAID, HE FORGOT THE DATE OF
AN EMAIL THAT YOU FORWARDED AND
YOU WENT AND TOLD THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE THAT THEY
MADE THAT MISTAKE, AND THEY
ALLOWED YOU TO AMEND YOUR
TESTIMONY.
BUT THEN AT A LATER TIME WHEN
YOU DIDN'T SAY WHAT THEY WANTED
YOU TO SAY, THEY CAME BACK TO
PROSECUTE YOU FOR LYING.
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> THEY HADN'T RELOADED THE
FIRST DAY OF TESTIMONY AND I HAD
FORGOTTEN ABOUT TWO EMAILS.
WHEN I FINALLY LOADED THE TIME
MACHINE, I REALIZED THESE EMAILS
WHERE THEY ARE.
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HE ALLOWED  A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HE ALLOWED  L
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HE ALLOWED  W
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HE ALLOWED  D
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HE ALLOWED  M
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HE ALLOWED  E
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HE ALLOWED  T
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HE ALLOWED  O
AMEND THE TESTIMONY, AND IN THE
ONE COUNT I WANTED TO PLEAD
GUILTY TO, THEY WANTED TO CHARGE
ME WITH KNOWINGLY AND WILLFULLY
GIVING FALSE INFORMATION ON THE
ORIGINAL DAYS MISTAKE, NOT
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THAT THEY
HAD ALLOWED ME COME THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR, TO AMEND THE
TESTIMONY WHICH I THOUGHT WAS
COMPLETELY FRAUDULENT.
>> Tucker: IS CERTAINLY ODD
AND MOST LAWYERS THAT WE HAD
SPOKEN TO HADN'T HEARD OF
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
WHY WERE THEY PRESSING YOU ON
THAT?
>> FROM DAY ONE, THEY BLEW UP.
THEY SAID THEY WOULD HAVE ENOUGH
TO THROW ME IN PRISON BECAUSE I
HAVE GOTTEN THESE EMAILS.
I'M CONVINCED IT WAS ALL
STRATEGY.
I WENT IN TO COOPERATE.
I GAVE MY COMPUTERS, I GAVE MY
TIME MACHINE, I HANDED OVER
VOLUNTARILY MY EMAILS AND MY
TWITTER ACCOUNT, ET CETERA.
EVERYTHING THEY WANTED.
THE FIRST DAY IS A MEMORY TEST,
I DON'T GET THE MEMORY TEST
RIGHT AND SUDDENLY I WILL BE
THROWN IN PRISON FOR THE REST OF
MY LIFE.
IT'S AN INTIMIDATION TACTIC AND
I'M QUITE CONVINCED IT'S
INTENTIONAL.
>> Tucker: INTIMIDATING YOU TO
GET YOU TO DO WHAT?
WHAT DO THEY WANT YOU TO DO THAT
YOU REFUSE TO DO?
>> THE KEY THING IS THEY WANTED
ME TO BE THE KEY LINK BETWEEN
ROGER'S OWN, TO ME, TO JULIE AND
MASSAGE.
THEN ROGER STONE TO STEVE BANNON
AND DONALD TRUMP, IN
COORDINATION WITH MASADA.
M.
ON THAT FLIGHT I CALCULATED AND
FIGURED OUT -- I HAVE NEVER MET
HIM OR EMAILED HIM, AND I HAVE
NO CONTACT WITH ANYONE WHO IS IN
TOUCH WITH HIM.
AND THE PROSECUTORS REFUSED TO
BELIEVE THIS.
SO IT LED TO GRILLING AFTER
GRILLING AFTER GRILLING.
CONSTANTLY -- THEY HAVE AN
8-INCH THICK BOOK WITH MY NAME
ON IT AND MR. ZELINSKI, ONE OF
THE PROSECUTORS, WON'T TELL ME
IF IT'S ALL ABOUT ME.
THEY ARE ASKING ME QUESTIONS AND
PULLING FILES OUT AND SAYING
THIS EMAIL CONTRADICTS IT.
WELL I DON'T REMEMBER THAT
EMAIL, I DON'T REMEMBER IN
DETAIL ANY OF MY EMAILS.